we went by
bicycle no automobile available because
of wartime restrictions on their
use on the way home my condition began
to assume threatening
forms everything in my field of vision
wavered and was
distorted as of seen in a curved
mirror
[Applause]
I also had the sensation of being unable
to move from the
[Music]
spot nevertheless my assistant later
told me that we had traveled very
rapidly from the Diary of Albert Hoffman
Swiss chemist
[Music]
Switzerland has long been obsessed with
the science of the
Mind take Albert
Hoffman he was the first person to
synthesize
LSD on April 19th 1943 he ingested a
tiny amount hopped on his bike and then
realized that all matter is merely
energy condens to a slow vibration there
is no such thing as death and we are the
imagination of our
ourselves today Swiss labs and medical
companies are still pushing the
frontiers of our understanding of the
mind there's less blot involved but
they're very much turned on and tuned in
to a unique mix of Neuroscience
computers and
AI the research can be dazzling it can
sometimes feel like you need an IQ of a
thousand to understand
it but more and more I'm seeing that
we're on the cusp of things that used to
be called
Miracles and know you're going to turn
on the stimulation and they do a leg
extension and up the steam is on now how
does it feel when it turns on like that
it's uh
fantastic six years ago Michelle here
was in an accident that left him unable
to move his legs at
all then he had electrodes implanted on
his
spine and well check him
[Music]
out he's one of the first patients
treated by onward which has created a
technology to help reconnect paralyzed
people's brains with their
bodies the idea comes from a brain
surgeon and a
neuroscientist Joselyn BL and grea
cortine several years ago grea was
studying paralyzed rats at UCLA and came
up with a way to get their legs moving
again so very simple Approach at the
beginning stimulating the spinal cord
electrically the region that normally
control leg muscles anatomically intact
after a spinal cord injury but
disconnected from the
brain and it was quite amazing because
as as you apply the stimulation the
animal would start stepping
automatically on the
treadmill when I met him I saw the the
mice and rats walking and it was
fantastic the idea was to bring it to
the human being I don't think like the
average person knows that this is even
possible right now maybe explain like
what you're finding people are able to
do if you have a spinal cord injury your
brain is intact giving a command to your
legs but this command is interrupted at
the level of the injury and the idea of
the treatment is to reactivate the
disconnected part of the spinal cord in
order to then activate your legs so how
do you activate this part of the spinal
cord with
electricity so this is what we call the
paddle lead it has 16 electrodes as you
see here eight and eight in parallel and
we implant this paddle leads in the
dorsal aspect above the spinal
cord the electrodes get implanted on a
different part of the spine depending on
what the patient is trying to do place
them on the lower spine and you can get
the legs
moving when the first patient stood up I
don't know in my head I'm picturing
everybody like crying and hugging what
was it like or is it
more you are in
Europe Italian a lot of emotion there
was a lot of bad WS yeah yeah yeah yeah
so but it was a big
emo in other patient the electrodes are
placed higher up on the spine to help
regulate blood pressure a less obvious
but equally life-changing
effect my name is Julie I'm 23 years old
and I'm an
archaeologist one year and a half ago we
had a major car accident in
Serbia and I basically broke my neck my
condition of blood pressure issues got
so bad that I was basically like what
you guys were looking for in the study
and then we came here and um yeah and I
got implanted I did not know that blood
pressure issues or something that's
that's quite common with this type of
injury but I but it is without I mean my
blood pressure is so low that I'm
basically just stuck in bed all the time
even just sitting up in a wheelchair is
like running a marathon yeah it also has
a huge impact on my mental state of mind
yeah without the stimulation
there is so little oxygen circulating in
my brain that there is not much joy in
life let's say and then when you turn it
on it's like back to some sort of normal
level and it's just the increase of
energy being able to breathe and speak
at the same time I'm able to make plans
to travel to just have a more positive
outlook on life in general
now it's still a little bit of warm
[Music]
up Michelle is a young man who had a
motorbike accident a few years ago
already with a complete motor and
sensitive paralysis okay and this is a
real athlete he trained a lot with us
and he's using this technology every day
many
hours they have two buttons one per side
every time I press I uh send the signal
to the tablet and uh I I have the
movement I make the
[Music]
step the walk may be strained but it's
good enough that Michelle is mostly able
to get around without a wheelchair and
the implant lets him do other kinds of
exercises too he has a program that just
Target the region of The Spar cord
involving trunk muscle so he's uploading
the
program just pressing a button I have
the six pack oh wow I need this
[Laughter]
program rather fantastically Michelle
whose legs were completely paralyzed has
regained a tiny amount of home grown
organic muscle control something in my
body is changing now is appearing some
uh twitch on the muscles okay under
delion yeah we know that the residual
nerve fibers because there are always
some residual nerve fibers they grow
because of the stimulation and that
improve the communication to the point
that they can reg control over the
paralyzed
muscles the doctors don't know how far
the regrowth of nerve fibers can go go
with only a handful of patients
implanted so far there's still much to
learn but there are other ways that
Joselin and grea want to push the tech
forward they have started to combine
brain computer interfaces with the
spinal implants that is to say they're
putting electrodes in the brain and on
the spine and having them communicate
this lets patients simply think about
actions like walking or swimming and
have their bodies pick up on their
desires what do you think you going uh
brain
implants h i to with my
[Laughter]
hair two years ago onward went public
and raised $100
million they're still in the clinical
trial phase with much of this work but
are on track to become the first company
to commercialize these kinds of
implants the hope is to get them covered
by insurance and accept ible to the
millions of people around the world
living with spinal cord injuries every
time I see him progressing each time I
see him it's very rewarding on the other
hand it's very frustrating because I
would like to see 1,000 Michelle it's
very cool and I can tell you're you're
very
focused every day I want even more every
time I want
[Music]
more as verer Herzog said the fountain
is life or a tourist attraction it's
totally up to
you this is uh Geneva's Fountain hotspot
it's beautiful
ejaculatory everything you could want in
a
fountain you want me to do a straighter
one I'm not going to lie I didn't
exactly do my homework on the touristy
bits of
Switzerland is this Lake Geneva
let's find
out I'm not getting a clear answer on
that but we're going to go with
it it's nice as you can see but me I'm
just here for the
brains and in cities like Zurich and Lan
you can find some of the world's brain
research
hotspots here neuroscience and computer
science mix promiscuously with wildly
creative
results for example this lab full of
rodent twitch streamers run by animal
research Superstar McKenzie matthysse so
it sounds a little bit far out but we
really teach mice to play video games
and use little joysticks like Pilots um
but the cool thing about this is is that
we then allow to see how they learn
these different skills and how they
adapt and at the same time can record
the neural activity and we hope to turn
sort of the lessons learned in the brain
into literally new AI
algorithms what are we going to see
today so today we're going to take you
into the lab and show you some of the
latest gen video games for
mice they're kind of in a freely moving
World um but all the world is a screen
and it changes based on their real-time
movements this is the VR World exactly
are we going to put a mouse we're going
to put a mouse in here yeah
so if I'm not mistaken this is uh an
chovi and Barracuda so who is that this
is
anchovy and's
off it's this idea of they're learning
this game they're facing challenges or
they're going through this environment
and it's just what is the brain doing
when as they try to like negotiate that
and figure things out yeah exactly oh
what did she do she made the things
appear by standing in the middle and
then facing with the right heading angle
at the
screen anovi may be impressive but she
has yet to enter her final
form so in order to be able to measure
the neural activity what we do for part
of the experiments is to replace the top
of the skull with a glass
plate behold Mouse
brains this Mouse had this surgery and
now she's learned to play this game
I think the mouse try so
funny the mice themselves are
genetically engineered such that in some
neurons their neurons are actually glow
green and then you can capture this with
the camera and then we can extract sort
of the regions of interest from all
these different neurons and then analyze
them in relation to the actual gameplay
or the actual behavior of the
animal the ultimate goal is to turn
these mousy thoughts into
Data McKenzie wants to record how brains
function in certain situations and use
those insights to inform and shape AI
systems in other words she wants to use
real brains to make better artificial
brains we hope by trying to understand
like literally the algorithm or the
computations like are they using
arithmetic is it calculus like what are
they doing and how can we potentially
take those sort of computations and then
test them in new AI algorithms uh so
that's the general
idea
mice are nice and all but they're not
the only Critters having their brain
scanned here at Swiss research
institutes these are our fly stocks so
each and every single one of these um
Fly vials contains uh flies that are uh
genetically
distinct meet Anamaria Yaki the queen of
the Flies we normally have to
anesthetize them because their flies
they fly so we have to kind of keep them
uh nice and
still your objective is to find males
versus females let's let's do that the
male is the dark butt right yeah yeah
that's correct that's right yeah yeah
you're a
natural so our basic question in our lab
is in complex environments you have to
learn where things are you have to
memorize things so we're trying to kind
of recreate these situations for the
flies and we try to to evolve cognition
in flies so you're trying to make super
smart flies yeah exactly fly Mastermind
what could go wrong like this yeah so
you breed smarter and smarter flies you
get them to do these tasks you find
which ones perform the best take those
breed them again
exactly it's basically fly
Eugenics but how do you separate the
flystein from the
fimbel with a fly Q test of course
so right now we are uh conditioning
flies to pick one color in a set of two
or three colors they're picking between
green or blue every single fly at the
very end of the experiment we'll get a a
learning score we get rid of the 10% of
the worst performers and we take the the
majority of the FES
so as she breeds generation after
generation of bugs Anamaria hopes to
learn about the relationship between
genes and
intelligence we can trck specifically
what are the genes that are being
selected for cognitive behaviors how
specifically does the brain actually
change in its structure and all of this
we can actually use um for wet wear so
instead of using um physical chips we
can use biological chips like neurons
itself to actually power our computers
someday in the future you know I think
every scientist I've interviewed for the
show so far just about is like trying to
make AI smarter and better and it's the
ultimate kind of goal to see how to
produce ourselves
[Music]
right in many ways even the tiniest
corporeal brains are smarter than our
best AIS so the researchers here think
that studying these creatures is our
best shot at creating things like highly
capable robots if we could build an AI
that could do what a mouse does I think
that would be a huge feat for Humanity
maybe within 10 years we could have you
know Mini Mice robots not that we want
that for Humanity but conceptually right
we want something like an embodied age
that they can act in the world and very
adaptively change its Behavior just
pictured like New York full of robotic
AI mice horrifying that would be pretty
scary of course the brain I want most to
understand is my own so I decided to
volunteer as a test
[Music]
subject okay friends ready to go down
the rabbit
[Music]
hole this lab at the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology is run by an
eccentric psychonaut named Olaf Blanc
he invited me to try an experiment
that's meant to induce the feeling of a
ghostly
presence real talk I'm a little bit
scared but first let's get existential
with
Olaf so I've been interested for a long
time in the self and how it is related
to our our body how the brain actually
represents our body how are my hands
represented my body how is your brain
representing your
body what gives us the conscious
experience of being someone of being a
person we're looking at something very
perceptual we call it a minimal self and
we think that this minimal self is
crucial for feeling that I'm feeling
right now sitting in front of you here
talking to you so this very like basic
fundamental connection between mind and
and body exactly so it's an active brain
process yeah on a millisecond by
millisecond basis we have to generate
this representation where we are in
space and it better be here where my
body is located this for granted but
this process is happening all the time I
think much of well excepts when it
isn't think outof body experiences or
feeling a ghostly presence in the
room anomalies that Olaf first
encountered while treating patients with
neurological disorders they were talking
for example that before they have an
epileptic seizure they may have an outof
Body Experience okay and of course they
didn't use that term but they were
saying yeah listen Ola it was strange I
was I had the sensations for about a
couple of seconds that I was above
myself or it could have been a presence
hallucination or ghost sensation I
remember one patient in particular who
told me well there's somebody just at
arm length behind me and whenever she
got up and moved that person moved along
okay so very strange so is your theory
that stories of ghosts over time this is
kind of where it all comes from is some
yeah so people having these feelings if
you want a naive quick response yes
that's what it
is it turns out these Sensations are a
common symptom of Parkinson's
disease so the presence hallucination
feeling somebody behind you that is not
there that you can hear that you can't
see 50% of Parkinson patients will have
that naturally this inspired Olaf to
figure out how to induce these
hallucinations on demand using VR and
Robotics so you will be sitting on this
chair and your main task will consist in
moving this robot
okay can you confirm you are in the dark
environment right now yeah it's yeah
nothing just black oh there you are you
can see that he's immersed inside a
virtual room which is mimicking this
real experimental room so it's a
recreation of the room in
[Music]
3D as I move my hand to poke a virtual
Avatar a robot behind me gave me a
corresponding poke it's all meant to
confuse your brain so much that you
start to sense the presence of another
being while Olaf studies what's going on
in your
brain thank you okay perfect that was
weird sometimes I sort of thought I was
doing it then sometimes it really felt
like almost like an animal or something
was kind of needing in my the sensation
for me was not all that strong but
that's partly the
[Music]
point since Parkinson's patients are
more susceptible to the illusion than
others the experiment could function as
a kind of early warning system for the
disease with the robotic device we don't
need to wait for the symptoms we don't
need to wait for the patient to have
Parkinson but we could expose people to
this much earlier if they have other
risk factors and if they would be part
of this very elevated sensitivity we
could team up for example with companies
starting very early neuroprotective
therapies trying to delay the onset of
Parkinson or cure
Parkinson what an exciting time between
VR prank computer interface artificial
intelligence I mean it must be like
exhilarating to have this intersection
no so no it's absolutely so I I think
what is what is special about at this
time I think when I started Neuroscience
was Neuroscience you know philosophy was
philosophy and certainly engineering was
engineering there was always an interest
in in medical applications but what what
is really amazing Happening Now is it
doesn't matter anymore right we all
working on similar problems and and and
issues and want to want to resolve
this the brain is I think by definition
something that's fascinating for
everyone and it needs expertise from all
these domains I think to have even a
chance to understand small parts of
it 80 years after Hoffman's psychedelic
ride Switzerland's brain research
complex is still going
strong but the mysteries of the Mind
remain
mysterious we still don't really know
how billions of neurons firing creates a
thought or how to fully restore a broken
connection between mind and
body researchers here will be on this
quest for a long time to come come but
it's a journey worth taking and I'm
excited to see what's
next that is as long as it's not AI
rodents bent on our
[Music]
destruction